usually the spring-break holiday would
see California's beaches packed but this
state was the first to order its
residents to stay at home an early
lockdown that seems to be paying on a
place with twice the population of New
York has had a fraction of the deaths
hundreds rather than thousands and a
governor unveiling a plan for a long
road back to normal it will not be a
permanent state we recognize the
consequences of these stay at home
orders have a profound impact on the
economy your personal household budget
your personal prospects around your
future but governor's like him face an
unlikely opponent Donald Trump meeting
survivors of the corona virus at the
White House has already claimed only he
has ultimate power to reopen the country
when somebody's the President of the
United States the authority is total and
that's so it's got to be the governors
and the Constitution disagree I mean
it's just a factual statement that is
factually wrong Tenth Amendment to the
Constitution it's a whole body of case
law there are lessons in the lockdown
from the west coast where Silicon Valley
Giants like Apple told staff to work
from home days before government orders
when I started writing about this three
and a half weeks ago the number of cases
in San Francisco in the number of cases
in New York were essentially the same
doctors saw the number of cases fall
dramatically the next phase could be
harder the last month or two months has
been brutally hard but but amazingly
easy in terms of messaging the next
phase I think has to be far more nuanced
because we don't have a vaccine we don't
have effective treatments there's
nothing about the virus that has changed
in terms of its deadliness but even here
there are dissenters this police video
showing 150 people arriving at an
underground nightclub for two days of
secret partying it's now been shut down
whatever the authorities say they need
the public to do as they're told
Greg Milam Sky News Los Angeles